channing tatum what were you thinking
this look says i am the douchiest elf in
all of middle-earth wait wait I have
more dishes for Channing Tatum he looks
like link from Twilight Princess if he
od'd on HGH he looks like a level 63
blood elf who moonlights at Chippendales
he looks like Peter Pan with several
extra Y chromosomes he looks like a
version of spot from a parallel universe
where everyone is fabulous he looks like
a Yuuzhan Vong's profile picture on
grindr i assessed the new movie Jupiter
ascending on this week's episode of
angry nerd first your comments I asked
you what you thought of the Jupiter
ascending trailer the kindest comment
was that it looked like a ripoff of the
indie RPG stars without number most
comments just bagged on Tatum's ears and
his parrot use of eyeliner good call
buddy Smith he does look kind of like
Mugatu in Zoolander he's absolutely
right the Wachowskis new movie is a
target-rich environment for starters the
protagonist is named Jupiter Jones what
she had distant cousin of Pluto Nash but
what really Broyles my bantha is that
the movie is about a janitor who's
genetic signature proves that she's a
descendant of galactic rulers I hate
this strain of sci-fi stories in which
the characters are fated to succeed now
predestination isn't a new storytelling
crunch but it's lazy it's positively
futile it's unamerican heroism is about
smarts and adaptability with maybe some
bravery in a self-sacrifice thrown in
but fate or kismet no thank you this
kind of thing reduces in epic saga to a
silly schoolboys daydream that he'd one
day develop mutant powers and then he
teach a lesson to all of the bullies who
mocked his jean-luc Picard lunchbox and
forced him to call home in tears and say
mommy I don't want to go to college
anymore
uh which happened to a friend of mine
lana and andy wachowski you don't return
my text messages but hear me out while
you're working on your upcoming Netflix
show since a try to make sure that the
characters aren't already a lot to save
the world in the pilot episode in fact
maybe do away with the characters
altogether you know like you did in
speed racer which movie hero do you
think had an unfair advantage over their
foes let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel also you
are predestined to click on my other
videos that are over here to my left and
your right like them add comments to
each of them do it fulfill your galactic
destiny